chained up grandma puke up a tarball and
oh god what is that because we have
quite possibly the most up ending to a
television show ever leave it to the
Europeans to release Aris a story about
a Dutch secret society that may or may
not be holding a demonic entity now I
have to preface everything by saying
this show has a lot of flaws and
definitely isn't for everyone
but the ending is just so out there I
had to cover it so even if you haven't
seen the show you're in for a wild ride
the final episode begins with Carmen
after she was unable to kill a baby as
part of her initiation to become
president of Aris you know your typical
initiation you see in order to become
president one must show they are willing
to make an ultimate sacrifice that they
are willing to give up the guilt that
holds them back from doing bad things
this test manifests itself in different
ways for different people Arnold for
example had to kill this woman and Yost
had to kill this person who is likely
his father but it's never really
expanded upon and then that brings us to
Rosa
the protagonist of the show who later
has to decide whether or not she's gonna
kill her best friend Jacob at the end of
episode 7 Moritz the head of Aras who
holds sway over which student becomes
president is approached by his daughter
Carmen who proclaims she's the right one
for the job she has spent her entire
life working towards this she's
experienced and ambitious she is tired
of seeing Rosa rise up the ranks even
though she's just a novice morts is
smart instead of denying her daughter
the chance to become president outright
he knows deep in his heart that Carmen
lacks the one thing it takes to be
President
sacrifice that's why when Karan is
confronted with killing the baby he
knows she won't go through with it
Carmen finds Jacob who is being held
captive for the suspected murders of
Arnold and Yost in Episode two Jacob
became infected by beiow and entity as
we'll come to learn is the manifestation
of everyone's guilt he did this by
touching a secret hidden wall in the
basement of the society where beiow is
supposedly hidden but before he can be
fully taken over he's saved by Rosa and
the infection only
to two of his fingers this infection
gets progressively worse and we'll find
out any time Jacob touches someone with
them they are reminded of the guilty
things they've done in their past which
drives them to commit suicide jacob
pleads with Carmen that she must tell
Rosa to release beiow
he knows Rosa is in line to become
president and only she has the power to
do so but what exactly is beiow
the L is our guilt the bad things that
fester and eat away at ourselves by
vomiting up these black tar like balls
the members of Aris feed bail and do
away with the guilt so they can live
unfazed by the horrors of their past
crimes as we see later on in the show
members of Aris did terrible things
dating all the way back to the 16th
century like slavery for example in
order to get ahead in the world one must
do terrible things lie cheat steal
murder but BAE L allows you to do those
things and not feel the guilt associated
with it earlier in the season Carmen
asked Rosa how she thinks such a small
country such as the Netherlands became
so powerful it's because Aras who
control and have controlled prominent
members of society for the past 500
years were able to do terrible things in
order to stake the Netherlands place in
the world they were willing to make
terrible sacrifices in order to achieve
power the same can be said for Rosa's
journey she uses her power to kick floor
out of the internship program not to
mention she disregards her father's
wishes to look after her suicidal mother
and decides to go to a party this all
culminates in her greatest sacrifice
killing her best friend Jacob but before
we get there Rosa is visited by Moretz
just before her initiation as president
we learned that Moritz was once engaged
to Rose's mother Joyce before Joyce ran
off to be with Rosa's father
Joyce is suicidal tendencies now make
more sense she was likely unable to give
up her guilt to be out before she ran
off and thus has lived with this guilt
for the remainder of her life Moritz
reiterates to Rosa that the ability to
make sacrifices separates leaders from
followers that society requires of its
leaders sacrifice in order for
to thrive and if Rosa is to be president
she must prove herself by making such a
sacrifice meanwhile the RS alumni have
gathered for the initiation of the new
president Moritz addresses them saying
Aris has been out of balance for years
not even the innocent youth can restore
this balance in the past VL fed off the
guilt of the young and innocent in order
to sustain itself but lately this hasn't
been working Aras has lost the power at
once held in the world and thus Moritz
says it's time for radical change Rosa
is the encapsulation of this not only is
she younger than all previous presidents
but she's a woman of color it's a
departure that Moritz believes will
steer the society in the right direction
at the initiation as all the Alumni
watch Rosa is tasked with killing her
best friend Jacob this is her sacrifice
interestingly enough it's Jacob who
tells her to go through with it he knows
he's slowly being taken over by the
guilt his time is ending but he TAS her
was setting the Alfre for good the
question is will she do it
meanwhile outside eres Rosa's father
meets up with Carmen who it seems has
decided to leave the group he knows how
evil Aras is after what it did to Joyce
and now it seems the same thing is
happening to his daughter in the
basement of Aris Rosa is taken to a
white circular room where a swirling
black liquid flows in its center Moritz
tells her that BL isn't a person or
thing it's him it's her it's everyone
it's a story something to fear he turns
his attention to the black water older
than Amsterdam itself in fact no one
knows how old it is the water is
comprised of everything there members
expel from their bodies the guilt and
things they don't want to talk about
they use the waters potential to make
decisions others can't even think about
this allows them to rise to positions of
power without the weight of guilt on
their shoulders Rosa collapses to the
ground ready to vomit out the guilt of
killing Jacob as we get glimpses of this
old woman saying the darkness inside of
me is what I give to you this is the
same woman we saw a few episodes earlier
when Moritz was a young man she hasn't
aged a bit but who exactly
is she these simple answer is that we
don't know that likely being a threat
for season two however judging by her
shackles and how she's imprisoned by
Aras it's likely they're using her for
her power she's likely some ancient
entity that has been captured and her
power harnessed for nefarious purposes
it is now up to Rosa to set her free
instead of throwing up her guilt Rosa
contains it part of it seeping out of
her eyes she makes the greatest
sacrifice at all throwing herself into
the Blackwater it's here we are revealed
one of Arce's biggest crimes slavery one
of the ways aris rose to power and
prominence was by enslaving thousands
mort says ours had been using this black
water for 500 years which lines up with
the Dutch slave trade of the 1600s I
actually would have liked to seen other
nefarious things
Aras did throughout history to further
nail this point as more swatches on the
flow of water schnapps and as soon as
this happens he knows something has gone
dreadfully wrong with Rosa emerging from
the water completely covered in this
black liquid so too has centuries of
guilt built up by its members been
unleashed on the world she appears in
front of the alumni who watch on in
horror some of the patrons even go so
far as to kill themselves a result of
the guilt returning back to them as Rosa
makes her way past alumni who have taken
their own lives flashes of paintings
appear on screen
some of them depicting Dutch wars others
including men in high positions of power
likely members of Aras this one for
example is the 1669 Carol Dujardin
painting the Regents of the spin house
which depicts local merchants who were
getting rich off the goods manufactured
by the Dutch Empire trade which involved
exploitation slavery and domination of
foreign colonies and people's but
perhaps the most important painting
shown is the threatened Swan by yon ah
salon this is the painting Rosa looks at
way back in episode 1 it shows a swan
defending an egg from a dog carmen tells
Rosa that the egg represents Holland and
the dog is outside forces threatening it
although she never explicitly says it
the Swan is meant to represent Aras as
being the protector of Holland all of
these paintings showing Dutch power are
juxtaposed to the car
and violence once be al has been
released Rosa makes her way to the
president's office where she finds
Morris has already cut off his face with
a pair of scissors I can't even show it
because it is so explicit we don't know
exactly what Moretz did in the past but
it must have been pretty bad she stoic
Lee makes her way over to the
president's chair and sits down ironic
that her ascent to power has also
resulted in the destruction of the
organization that brought her to it but
even weirder is the appearance of her
father who comes in and gives her a hug
he is unafraid and there are no words
spoken between the two that's because he
has nothing to be afraid of
he has no guilt or at least has learned
to live with it Rosa's father represents
the opposite of Aris a follower who
leads a good and just life rather than a
leader who did unfathomable but the
ending still leaves us with several
unanswered questions
who exactly is or was this chained
person as Moritz says earlier BAE L is
not a person it's more an idea or a
story
thus this chained person is more so a
metaphor than an actual physical being
it is the years of guilt locked and
shamed away struggling to get out it is
only when Rosa jumps into the pool of
black liquid that she becomes the
personification of this guilt if there
is a season - Rosa will be infused with
all the memories guilt and trauma of the
Auris society which makes her a danger
to them and their existence which could
make for an interesting season - with
her either being hunted down or her
hunting them down the biggest mystery
for me however is the old lady who
doesn't seem to age how does she fit
into everything the fact Aras has her
locked up means she's either dangerous
or Aras is exploiting her for her power
perhaps a combination of both with Aris
seemingly destroyed what will become of
her and what will her relationship to
Rosa be was Aras doing something good by
keeping her chained up or were they
doing something evil keep in mind the
only person ever to really interact with
her was Moretz so it's possible this was
someone in his imagination some part of
his past that he's held on to I will say
that the existence of Aras also calls
into question the existence of other
such
groups is there perhaps an English
secret society that also harnesses this
power an American one how far does the
lore behind be Alan it's linked to the
history of the world go unfortunately we
don't know if Aris has been picked up
for season two but with Aris being a
relatively cheap show to put on and the
rise of horror TV shows I wouldn't be
surprised if it got picked up even
considering some of the shows less than
favorable reviews if you want to join my
secret society guilt-free please
consider subscribing and hitting that
like button I come up with tons of
breakdowns fan theories and ending
explain videos so you want to stick
around for that you can also reach out
to me on Twitter at things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much